i think that it's really important to
point out donald trump uh yesterday i
heard him say that he was tired of joe
biden talking about how russia has
nuclear power and is a nuclear force and
it sounds like you know when you say
that that you're scared and president
trump said you know what joe biden
should be saying
we
are in nuclear power and we know what to
do and that i think therein lies the
difference is that donald trump was no
wimp
he wasn't anyone who just said you know
i want to bring troops home and avoid
war
he built up the defense department he
built up america's power he used the
power with soleimani he he was really
able to to show
an unpredictability when it came to
using america power america's power but
he has his criteria and this is i think
a really important point what is best
for the u.s
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the former u.s ambassador to germany as
well as the former acting director of
national intelligence for these great at
least great for now
united states of america and my friend
and californian we're gonna have to get
into that
rick grinnell welcome back to the reuben
report
dave thanks for having me always a
pleasure
let's just do the california thing quick
in one minute what the high hell are you
doing there still man
i love this place i can't leave i can't
abandon it um it's bad um look today's
the filing deadline for uh people
running for governor senate
congressional races all the races
doesn't look like we're going to have
any major candidate running against
newsome
uh and i think that's just more of a
commentary on the fact that the system
here is broken they do mail-in ballots
uh democrats completely rule this place
like a third world country and so
therefore we really don't have
uh competition
you know rick i knew it was bad in cali
when i was calling people to say i was
leaving and i thought you were going to
be the one guy because you were trying
to clean up the rolls there and you're
still trying to do a whole bunch of
stuff and i know how much you love
california you've been there forever
but i was calling people to say i'm
leaving and and everyone was like oh
great you know you should go it's time
to go get out of dodge and you i we're
the only person i thought was going to
say stay and you go
i get it and then i was like all right
i'm out of here by the way rick every
time i mention california on the show i
put money into this jar and at the end
of the year i'm going to be handing a
whole bunch of cash and i'm throwing in
a couple thousand dollars in my money
for somebody for somebody that's willing
to leave california and migrate to
florida so i thought i thought you were
going to say for somebody who needs to
help pay taxes uh because they stayed
there and so i'll gladly take the money
no i am not paying your taxes to king
newsom uh okay but let's let's get on to
the stuff that i i really wanted to talk
to you about this week because obviously
there's this whole russia ukraine
situation um
this is what you're an expert in as an
ambassador and on the intelligence side
and all that so i i thought maybe we
could start by just doing a little uh a
little 101 on what you think
american foreign policy should be like
so before we just jump into before we
get into the specifics of what's
happening in russian ukraine just
generally what you think america's role
in the world should be
and maybe how it was
when uh when you were working with that
orange guy versus how it is now let's
just start there and then we'll jump to
the specifics yeah look you know i think
that um the america first policy is a
fantastic one and it doesn't mean
america alone and it doesn't mean
uh just simply that we bring troops home
and we
ignore uh crises around the world i
think what america first means
is just that is that we put america
first we think about our u.s national
security that's the criteria
what is good for u.s national security
but it also means that our allies have
to stand up and we encourage them to do
so so it's why we we removed our u.s
troops in somalia because we said to
kenya hey can you kind of police your
own neighborhood it's why we wanted the
europeans to do more
and i i think there's an admission a
tacit admission from the germans right
now in terms of their policy
that
they believe that they were on the wrong
track for 10 16 years of merkel
they now are completely flipped they're
better than the senate democrats they're
better than joe biden because there's an
admission now that wow not paying your
nato
fair share of two percent was a huge
mistake so what did the germans do
they decided to say we're going to pay
it all at once in one year to catch up
this is a huge admission that they have
been on the wrong track for 16 years
then they turn around and they say we
got to stop this russian pipeline
this is historic this is unprecedented
don't forget just a few months ago
not very long ago
senate democrats the biden
administration and the government of
chancellor merkel in germany all came
together to say drop the sanctions on
putin on on the russian nordstrom 2
pipeline because they all said this may
encourage him
uh if we if we squeeze him too much he's
gonna lash out well obviously they were
wrong and they completely got it uh
upended and so the sanctions should have
been put on
or stayed on we should say but the the
democrats the binding administration
should have
kept that pressure on and i think that
we would have a different scenario but
when putin is looking at afghanistan and
by the way people are not talking enough
about the the uh policy that biden put
in place to drop the houthis from the
terrorist watch list
as soon as they did that dave we had
a couple of months later what did the
houthis do
they were bombarding the uae abu dhabi
was receiving missiles from the houthis
now this was by official washington
largely ignored there wasn't a
correlation made between hey you know
joe biden and the biden administration
all the democrats just took the houthis
off the terrorist list and what happened
they started acting like terrorists and
so
you you literally have to
push official washington to see that
these weak policies translate globally
into terrible
situations
i don't think it's too much to say that
joe biden's weakness is causing
war
scandal
uh destruction and and we have to be
able to shake the senate democrats
because the germans now see that
uh and it's i never thought i would see
it in my day and they're certainly not
saying rick grinnell was right donald
trump was right but they're coming awful
close so let's stick with that germany
situation for a minute because so you
were ambassador to germany under trump
and if you listen to the media
throughout all of that um you know trump
was mean and scaring people all the time
and you went in there and you weren't
listening to anybody and the other
ambassador wasn't happy with you and all
of this stuff however things were
basically working in terms of all of our
international agreements and we were at
least
trying to encourage people to pay a bit
more which as you just said now they're
catching up with uh did everything shift
overnight basically
once uh once biden took over
i think that there's a combination of
once biden took over and once merkel was
gone it was relatively at the same time
and you know merkelism really didn't
work we had 16 years of and and i'm
passionate about this subject is that i
believe that chancellor merkel
in making her policy germany first
she decided to move the german
uh
transatlantic relationship away from the
west instead of making a western-facing
alliance where you stand with the west
and you do things uh that benefit the
west
she decided to have a foreign policy
like switzerland and be everybody's
friend and to sell cars you know in
moscow and beijing and tehran and
everywhere else and and don't forget
when when i arrived in germany
uh i was walking around one day and i
and i walked past this
hotel youth hostel and i looked over and
it was literally i'm not exaggerating
the property of north korea
in the middle of berlin and i went back
to the embassy and i was like what the
hell there's
there's a there's a north korean hotel
youth hostel in the middle of berlin i
mean they're under international
sanctions this is illegal and there and
you know everybody at the state
department was like yeah but i guess
we've allowed that to happen and i said
no no no no guessing this is
unacceptable so i took it to chancellor
merkel and you know there were a lot of
excuses oh it's not really us it's it's
this management company and i said i
don't care it's in the middle of berlin
shut it down you're violating u.n
sanctions
they eventually shut it down they
weren't happy with me for pointing that
out
but i wasn't happy with them for
violating international sanctions my
point in telling you this is that
they've moved away from the west for 16
years well the german marshal fund has
just applauded them as you know this
great economic power
and yet i think that there's a
difference you can bifurcate the
transatlantic alliance from the western
facing
alliance the western alliance and and
merkel decided to just be a part of this
you know transatlantic alliance which
was not western-facing she's the one who
moved germany and europe away from the
west and now i think they're scrambling
to say
yikes we might have encouraged war in
ukraine
okay so with all of that in mind um none
of this happened for the four years
under the guy that you worked for and
everyone kept saying oh but trump is
putin's puppet and all of these things
and yet oddly putin made a move on
crimea when joe biden was vice president
and then he cooled it off for four years
and then made a move when biden was
president are any of these things
connected or am i a crazy conspiracy
theorist
i know you personally are not crazy uh
but don't forget that we should also put
in there though that um putin moved on
george under under uh bush under
president bush um this is not a partisan
statement to say that you've got to be
able to put america first and articulate
um the responses of of the u.s
government and you know i i think that
it's really important to point out
donald trump
yesterday i heard him say
that he was tired of joe biden talking
about how russia has nuclear power and
is a nuclear force and it sounds like
you know when you say that that you're
scared and president trump said you know
what joe biden should be saying
we
are a nuclear power and we know what to
do and that i think therein lies the
difference is that donald trump was no
uh
wimp
he wasn't anyone who just said you know
i want to bring troops home and avoid
war
he built up the defense department he
built up america's power he used the
power with soleimani he he was really
able to to show
an unpredictability when it came to
using america power america's power but
he has his criteria and this is i think
a really important point what is best
for the u.s
and i'll finish by saying you know the
state department needs to learn this
lesson because when you talk about
america first
and all of the great things about what
that means to be an america first
advocate
it doesn't mean america alone
and there's a way to articulate america
first and i believe this passionately
that america first helps our allies and
others when america is out front trying
to
push forward democracy human rights the
rule of law guess what every economy
benefits we see that inflation is spiky
now economies are not doing well when
america puts itself first capitalism and
the rule of law thrive that brings up
every other country we should have state
department uh ambassadors overseas who
articulate why an america first policy
is good for them there should be no
apologies about this it's better to have
america first than to allow russia or
china to put themselves first and i
think what we've seen from 16 years of
merkel it's much better for america
first than to put germany first
so who do you think biden is putting
first right now i mean we it seems like
a lifetime ago but literally only three
weeks ago right before this whole thing
started we had about a two week window
of every day where biden it sounded like
he was basically acting as putin's pr
guy he kept being like well he's
probably gonna go maybe he'll go these
are the 16 things we don't want him to
do here's a bunch of stuff he can do i
mean
what is our policy at this point
look um i don't want to get too
philosophical or or theoretical here but
the opposite of america first is
consensus especially consensus with the
europeans
and i spent eight years at the un and i
can tell you inside the security council
that anytime there's a policy or a
statement coming out of the security
council it's the lowest common
denominator of what 15 countries believe
and it's not putting america first
certainly not putting democracy human
rights
the rule of law first and so joe biden
is trapped in official washington
ideas that he wants to be loved by um
the world he talks you know i know all
these world leaders he really
prioritizes the applause from the
globalists and so when you think about
it he he really wants the europeans to
be pleased the reason he dropped the
sanctions on nordstrom 2 is because
merkel and the germans at the time asked
him to he maximized being with the
germans being with the europeans having
them love him look no further than the
iran deal uh iran deal two
and and now we we see the europeans
saying wait a minute this deal we're
gonna have to put it on ice because it's
going south when the europeans
are saying we need to stop this process
and the biden team is not the one
calling it first we've got a big problem
when you're behind the europeans but
this is the policy now i can go through
you know each area of the world look at
venezuela policy now we're moving and
transitioning into engagement again
which already failed with the
venezuelans simply because there's a
bunch of latin countries that want us to
do that and joe biden is leaning in and
letting them determine that policy the
same thing in the balkans i worked very
hard on kosovo serbia we had four
economic agreements you know what the
policy is now
let the europeans lead on this issue and
you know this is the whole 1990s crowd
filled with ngos that love to write
white papers and tell rich people to
give them money to to think about these
issues but they're not making at all
do you think that these people without
getting too far into the philosophical
part then do you think that that
he at least has competent people i mean
when you listen to kamala harris talk
about this stuff you know ukraine is
small russia is big even tony blinken i
mean all of they they don't sound
competent to me putting aside that you
may have a philosophical disagreement
with them on on what u.s strengths
should be or something like that do they
strike you as competent people but a
friend in need is a friend indeed dave
i mean look um you know they're not
competent and i i blame the sacramental
media for allowing kamala harris as a
woman and as a black person to rise and
win all of these different offices
simply because of her identity she
wasn't qualified she doesn't have the
capacity and i honestly will will double
down on that if you look there's no
possible way susan rice and ron clayne
did not prepare her with a good book
of of what to say and what to do and
what the policy was i don't think it was
a lack of preparation i think it is a
capacity issue that she doesn't
understand these issues um she's been
allowed to rise to the top
uh without any vetting from the media
there's been no uh push until she got
into the presidential and then the
national media a little bit we're like
wait you're not really ready and so she
imploded but the sacramento media
allowed her just to you know catapult
and take over
um i don't think she's qualified i think
anthony blinken should have been fired
after afghanistan
i don't understand why he's still around
he's totally weak wendy sherman the
deputy at the state department you know
her nickname is what do you want wendy
when she goes into negotiations she
gives away the store she did it in north
korea in iran with russia
i don't know how many times we're going
to put her forward she's the
terrible negotiator for the united
states
and then you know susan rice is behind
the scenes supposedly doing domestic
policy which she's not qualified for
but i think she's pulling the string of
of all of these other positions remember
susan rice when she was national
security advisor had two deputies at the
nsc one was avril haynes who runs the
intelligence program as dni
and the other was anthony blinken who's
now running uh the state department so
diplomacy and intelligence
all are really under susan rice they're
her deputies she chose them
and that just means obama is pulling the
strings you know there's this philosophy
and i think i agree with it
that uh barack obama couldn't be the far
left progressive that he really wanted
to be
because as a black man he was in he was
very nervous about being
you know somebody who was in the middle
and being accepted by all the the polite
sides and i find that to be a phony um
uh you know kind of analysis
but nevertheless
he he wasn't as progressive as people uh
said that he was going to be
but now unleashed in this obama third
term with a puppet like biden i think
the reality is is that susan rice and
ron klein and everybody from the obama
administration is back into this biden
team that the obama third term is
unleashed and they really are just using
joe biden as a puppet and as an empty
suit to kind of let go and and really
try all these hard left progressive
ideas since it's imploding
i think they now have a good scapegoat
where they can say you know
joe messed it up and maybe they'll try
to adjust i see them a little bit trying
to adjust
but they're not getting it fast enough
by the way what you're saying is not
like some crazy idea that obama wanted
the third term i mean there is that
famous interview of him saying boy i
wish i could have a third term where i
was behind the scenes basically acting
as the puppet master i mean it's his
words yeah so you know
you're not just pulling this out of
nowhere do you think that this mainly
boils down to
america's energy sector i mean if you
just listen to what we're talking about
suddenly in the last week and gas prices
going crazy eight dollars in in los
angeles really nuts stuff
that they keep now saying well this is
the time for the green new deal this is
the time for electric cars that in some
ways this is exactly what they wanted
it's scary to think that they would view
every
everything that's happening and somehow
come up with the idea that they got to
get more progressive and more lefty but
but they always do right
in the mirror
i think they are i think that they're
reading this and saying this is our
opportunity um it's crazy to think about
that they
uh are not looking at the highest
inflation and the highest gas prices um
and and the fact that
the american people are
you know overwhelmingly saying this is a
disastrous administration worse than
jimmy carter the numbers keep going down
um you've even got some democrats now
rising up and saying you know this this
blaming putin for the high gas prices is
ridiculous but you know you can't talk
about these issues without talking about
the the dutiful media in washington i
mean they're allowing this to happen i
mean the new york times cnn ap
the washington post
are literally
working for the ruling party if if we
saw this happening in another country we
would call it out we would say you don't
have free media you you have official
media of the democratic party of the
ruling party of of the president
and there's no question that the new
york times and the washington post and
the adp
work for the democrats they they can't
uh critique the democrats to save their
life and i think this is the crisis that
we find ourselves in because if you stay
in washington like joe biden does and
all of his people you know washington is
exploding
it's getting every time you go there's a
new crane and a new building and the
budgets are getting bigger and 30
trillion dollars in national debt
the joke is now on us that live outside
of washington why do we keep expecting
the media who live there the politicians
who live there the lobbyists who live
there
they're never going to tear down their
city
they want a bigger better city the only
way to drain the swamp is to dig
trenches with fresh water and get that
muck out
and that means we got to start sending
people who don't want to live work and
go to church in washington dc we need
people who want their social life back
in their home districts so they go they
vote and they leave i will tell you two
people who do that and that i i admire
uh
you know there's more than two but the
two that i see
constantly doing that is ron johnson and
ted cruz
their their lives are back in their home
states
and and that includes their social life
and and so
they're not part of washington and they
can make better decisions because of it
do you think trump has any regrets
related to not draining the swamp as
maybe more more qui i mean clearly the
swamp still exists right he's he's not
president and the swamp exists
do you think there were more things that
he could have done or it was almost just
an impossible thing to do within four
years or maybe that he didn't even fully
grasp the
severity of it how entrenched it was and
what he was really up against
so
i would say this is my opinion um i have
not had this conversation with president
trump
fully i've had it a little bit on the
sides but um i think by the end of the
administration by the end of the four
years there was an admission that uh you
really have to dig deep in washington
into the agencies and get your people
you remember when donald trump came
um he had he told me that he had never
stayed in washington dc overnight until
uh the week of his inauguration so he
was a true outsider he had participated
in some of the you know
donations for both sides and and the
processes but he was a true outsider
and so
coming in as an outsider he was thinking
like an outsider and he thought you know
i got to get the white house right i got
to get the loyalists there and you run
the government from the white house over
time i think he realized wait a minute
you got to really get
uh into the agencies and dig deep and
get your people in there and so there
was an admission that we had to do more
of that
you know i blame the people that were
really around him in the very beginning
not to say wait a minute you you got to
have loyalists across the board
um but i think that lesson was learned
through time and would have been fixed
in a second term
so i want to go more towards that but i
just want to back up for one second uh
on the russia ukraine stuff when you
hear from
some of your counterparts that are
probably still in some of these
ambassadorships and and still overseas
are are people quietly saying to you boy
we sure do wish that orange guy was
still around because this wouldn't have
happened because it seems fairly obvious
to me that this would not be happening
if trump was president
absolutely it's across the board um all
around i'll even go a little bit further
i'm getting
uh messages every single day from
foreign service officers at the state
department who are saying what a
terrible mess we have they're not happy
with blinking
they see this as weakness um i mean this
is a real problem and and they see it
and these are people that i know
personally um did not vote for for
president trump because i have great
relationships with them and they've told
me and we've sparred about this before
um but i respect so many foreign service
officers
uh in their work because they most of
them can salute the president and and
implement the policies of the president
even when they don't like the president
and so they can separate that um i
actually always found it refreshing to
have these political discussions with
people because the ones who were really
honest about yeah i'm a democrat and i i
think this way
it was much better because uh you could
trust them actually you could see their
work
and you knew they were implementing and
so i i have great friends who voted for
biden who are foreign service officers
and i love talking to them and it makes
a healthy environment but
many of them are admitting to me
that they uh they can't believe that
this is happening
so i had nikki haley on last weekend and
she said something similar and she also
said something that you sort of
referenced earlier about that the world
wants america to lead it it really
desperately does it loves to hate on
america in a way but also really wants
america to lead i sense that's really
what you think too that it's like if
it's not us
everybody just runs around like a
chicken without a head
yeah i mean look i think the for china
or china yeah you look you look at the
middle east you look at now europe
um and i would even put um the latin and
south america in this category um
there's an open admittance that uh under
trump everything was better
they're just they're literally able to
say that now
uh more than a whisper
and
they're right
they are right indeed i thought you were
giving me a long pause for a crushing
line there
they're right i mean what else can you
say you know so what do you think
yeah what do you think trump would be
doing right now i mean or or what would
he have done for the two weeks before
where biden was basically coaching putin
in what do you think trump would have
done then and now
so i hate this question and i and i the
reason why is is because you know now we
sit here and we have to answer the
question of now what would you do
between a terrible and a really terrible
choice um look if i were in charge if
that's the the hypothetical right if you
were in charge what would you do if i
was in charge um we kicked joe biden out
of the white house because really what
happened was is biden led us down a
terrible road we got to turn around and
go back
and fix this
but
i'm pissed off that we have to be
answering these questions of uh you know
now what are your choices between
terrible and really terrible if donald
trump had been in charge all along we
wouldn't be in this process uh that we
are now to to have a choice between bad
and really bad
um i do think that this goes back to
afghanistan
and the weakness that was showed
by literally having
a president of the united states appear
to be proud that he got 90 out and the
world you know held their breath and
were shocked and they looked at each
other and were like did he just say that
we left 10 behind and he's proud of it
everybody saw that
um you know you again i why is
secretary of state anthony blanken still
in his job
he has failed miserably so many times
and yet he still has a job i don't
understand that
well i think it's because the media runs
cover basically what you were saying
before about new york times washington
post and everything else so what do we
do about that i mean okay so you you
drain the swamp you start doing things
let's say trump's magically president
again and and you do the things that the
agencies you're talking about there's
still this media issue that that runs
cover
yeah
you gotta just ignore them i mean they
all have pay walls so don't pay it and
then you won't read it and um the
reality is is that with social media you
can educate the public
about what the government is doing and
be transparent that's the goal the goal
is to get information transparent
information honest information to the
american public we have developed the
system of a filter
that the media think that now they are
in charge of information to the american
people social media upended that just
like you know
our phones having uh our bank accounts
on it we don't have to go in and see the
teller anymore we get to go straight to
our account and we get to transfer money
and and control it
it's not unlike the media and that's why
i think they're clamping down on getting
trump off social media
they don't want to see a a debate they
want to control it so they're applauding
it
it's it's
terrible for this country it's why first
and second generation americans are the
loudest
pro-republican pro-trump group because
they left fascism they left
totalitarianism they know what it's like
and they see the signs with the media
some of the proudest members of the
america first crowd are first and second
generation americans you want to know
who the problem is in this country
seventh eighth generation white liberals
who haven't traveled enough
they don't understand how great america
is i'd like to have them travel a little
bit more and and then they will stop
tearing our country down and realize
that we're the greatest country in the
history of the world
yeah wait can you go a little further on
this sort of second generation like the
the we're now seeing a huge explosion in
conservative latinos that's one trump
made major inroads in the in the black
community it's a little unclear where
that sits now at the moment um but can
you talk about that because that seems
to me to be the the future of this thing
not because of the color of their skin
or even their ethnicity but because of
the value stuff yeah well look i don't
even think that it's just the the
hispanics and latinos anymore um you
know certainly we know the stories of of
cubans who have left totalitarianism and
fascism and they become this rabid
supporter of freedom but it's in miami
come visit me you'll see it
i have a joke about miami which i can't
say because they'll hold against me
forever but it's a very funny one i'll
tell you personally um i love miami and
i love south florida because it's so
filled with people who are freedom
fighters and if you've ever had a taste
of not freedom
you want freedom
and so i think what's happening too is
eastern europeans chinese americans
taiwanese americans people who have
lived on a russian americans i actually
have some friends in la who uh born and
raised in russia who live here they're
some of the most pro-trump
positive
uh love america patriots that you've
ever seen because they are like the
canary in the coal mine for what's
happening in our society for
institutions that take away
our freedoms and and i think you've got
to listen to first and second generation
americans tell the story of why they
came to america and and we have a
problem with those in this country who
don't travel
and who continue to think you know i'm
going to write a big check to blm or
something because i feel guilty and
america is a racist country
and
that's not what the people who are
coming here are seeing they're seeing a
great place filled with freedom and
democracy and opportunity and yet uh we
need to get these white liberals who
have been here for too long who i call
fat and happy we need to get them
traveling so that they can see how great
america is
you know rick you could correct me if
i'm wrong but i'm pretty sure that all
of those rich white liberals in beverly
hills never voted to defund their own
police isn't that bizarre
of course
really not their own
you know you've mentioned america first
a few times and i actually i spoke at a
republican congressional event here in
miami a couple weeks ago was for about
80 republican congressmen and i was
taking questions after and one of them
asked me
if they felt that the america first
branding was okay or was it too because
of the way the media talks about it was
it too associated with racism or white
supremacy or something obviously i know
you don't think that but but what do you
think that that uh
what do you do you think there's
anything that has to be done in terms of
branding so that when people hear
america first there isn't like some sort
of knee-jerk
reaction because of the way the media
talks about it
i mean or again it's ignore the media
yeah
i think you've got to ignore the media
and not play into them i mean they have
silly arguments everything is racist
sexist homophobic you know that
and i think the more you just ignore
them go straight to truth-telling social
media is really powerful to be able to
go straight to the people we got to do
more of that we need help from
republican senators to uh fix this big
tech problem of trying to of how they
try to silence us
um i think we got to grow our own media
i think it's okay to say that we're
always going to have media that are on
the left or the right that they bring
their personal bias into this
i think the danger comes when somebody
stands up and says i'm unbiased i am the
arbiter of all things and so
that person is dangerous because then
you know for sure they're they're a uh
silent liberal
yeah well scratchy progressive find an
authoritarian um sort of backing
backtracking again what what do you make
of just sort of the world wide response
to this you know in the last couple days
we're banning russian vodka now chase
and master carter booting russia from
their systems there's all this talk
about swift i mean that the whole
worldwide system not just nation states
but corporations
everything seems to be coming down on
russia does that feel organic to you
look i i think the corporate world is
group think right i mean right after
january 6
all the corporations were like we're not
going to give any money to any
republican and so it's this reactionary
thing um you know some of those same
companies uh refused to shut down their
operations in russia
i think it's okay that companies are
always going to act um in their own
financial interests we we understand
that they want to sell they want to make
money
the public has a big role to play here
you know how do we get people to to put
pressure uh so that human rights and
values become part of it and and i'm not
a purist you know i i will go shop at
places where they give most of their
money to democrats uh i'm i'm not going
to be one of those people but i there
are moments where i think you got to
take a stand i'm not a big uh believer
in
you know
saying that we're going to boycott
certain things but i think that you can
use your own power of your money you
have uh the the choice
um right now i think with with what
russia is doing
we should apply financial pressure
personal financial pressure and swift
and companies should recognize that this
is a belligerent moment from this
country but i also think that 69
countries criminalize homosexuality and
some of these same people who moralize
about oh i can't do business with russia
they're doing business with countries
that will put a gay person in prison
simply because they're gay and so where
does that line
stop um i'll also say you know i've
gotten hit from the foreign policy
establishment because i i said that i i
won't sign any letter that says we
should have a no-fly you know implement
a no-fly zone now or even a humanitarian
no-fly zone the idea that there's a
a light no-fly zone or a partial normal
zone is ridiculous
a no-fly zone is
meaning you're going to shoot down a
rush something yeah and and i'm all
against that i do think though that the
line in the sand is uh a nato ally we
have a treaty obligation an article five
wire is tripped if there's an attack in
poland or on a nato country
that's a different story because we got
to have
we got to set boundaries and we've got
to enforce boundaries what you see going
on in ukraine is heartbreaking though
it's terrible i mean i watch but all of
the media are focusing on that and i
continue to believe that
if the media all moved to the congo and
start telling us the stories of what's
going on in the congo there'd be calls
from neo-cons and others to have a
no-fly zone in the congo and then they'd
move to another country and it would
just be this perpetual problem
what we need to do as americans is
recognize
that the criteria that we have is what
makes america
less safe we have to respond to the
national security threats for america
never apologize about putting america
first because we are
largely a moral
country i don't think that we're perfect
and i'm not
saying that but i am saying that we have
the best system a checks and a balance i
mean every month our stats going out on
our economy and there's a whole industry
that will immediately say yeah that
number is higher or that number should
be lower you didn't include this
we have transparency in our country we
should be really proud of the system
because our system is the best while not
perfect
we should never apologize for this
system and and i think that's where we
have failed as we've allowed people to
really tear down the greatest system and
say it's not the greatest system
rick you just gave a beautiful ending
but i will ask you one other question
which is that as
a gay as they say will you come to
florida you can bring matt
and david and the four of us we will go
out to dinner and we will say gay in
front of people here in florida and see
what happens are you willing to take the
risk let's do it we'll be there
good seeing you my friend thanks for
joining all the best thanks dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell